bro I saw I Came Upon something on
online that's how about this dude and my
brother doesn't even believe that I like
this [__] for real but I do
[Music]
song mashups
and let me tell you why I like song
mashups because that that should be what
the song was
originally you don't agree with me okay
take two songs
that are good
Metallica
and Huey Lewis
you might go like this oh I love Huey
Lewis oh [__] yeah dude have to be
square amazing cool
hey you ever hear Metallica yeah what do
you like about Metallica I enter the
sandman oh you like into the same yeah
it's cool song but this bangs you know
the thing is
hold on a second
[Music]
bro this is the illest [__] I ever heard
you know you don't think it's good yet
check this out
[Music]
here we go
and here we go
bring it home
and then right here right here dude are
you kidding me
[Music]
oh dude it works that's about that they
made the greatest show they made a song
that trumps all other songs this guy
Bill McClintock on YouTube just [__]
killing it dude taking people's life
work and going like this nah check out
what this guy's life work boom and
creating
yeah yeah
are you
[Music]
not to never never Lions rough
dude rough the Never Never Land what
about this one dude what about this one
that he made this one might be even
better
oh I remember this Young MC I love Young
MC oh this one's a [__] classic
wasn't it yeah man it sure is oh [__]
that's such a great song What about
uh oh wait what the [__] is that Buffalo
well hold on a second what is this
Buffalo Springfield
[Music]
it's so much better than Young MC
[__] it all up
telling me I got to beware that's why I
like the patreon hey what's that sound
everybody look what's going down
and they still bring up the ladies come
on dude
that's so ill hey life's work great let
me put Let me link you up with some
other life's work
dude this is awesome
I love it if you don't love this [__]
this is the most American [__] by the
way if you don't love this [__] you're
not American
we're gonna skate to one song one song
only
this is a different guy right
[Music]
gotta hate this beat always did
wow biggie looks so big it was 12 when
he was murdered
[Music]
dude this is crazy
this is crazy they can do this
I'm just like I mean this kind of stuff
it makes me go rough to Never Never Land
psycho I'm black I can't wait till I get
to Tupac
Jordan
that sounds just like biggie dude I know
Tupac's voice so well so here comes
Tupac Let's see if it really sounds good
time
[Music]
let's go here we go is this gonna be two
boxes
[Music]
for like six days
whatever he would be doing right now
[Music]
oh [__]
soon to have it up yesterday
[Music]
this [__] just makes me miss [__]
Tupac That's So Dope
wow
AI huh
headed
putting Super Mario
Bros
[Music]
dude imagine what it's going to be like
in five years [__] yeah dude Tupac's
back dude I can't I can't wait for it
dude you bro I am going to only listen
to other rappers as Tupac this is so
great dude [__] yeah man
dude this is awesome this is straight up
[__] awesome
oh my god dude this is what it should be
Tupac AI music oh this is so ill I'm not
even [__] around I'm only
many many many men okay
[__] yeah dude
that's big why are they always having
him with biggie I just want
the ground
this is it dude
oh my god dude
[__] dude I found my new genre
are you kidding me
this is so dope I'm gonna start even
sing soggy songs I'm gonna do
he's a rich girl when you know it back
down and never caught up in Illinois
[Laughter]
dude we all live in a yellow submarine
yeah